good morning believe nation today's
message is find your confidence over you
Tom Cruise you have a voice as an artist
it's just getting your own confidence
and you find it just by doing it by
doing it and when you're playing that
character that is your character and
your instincts on the character are your
instincts on that character we're
constantly looking at life what is it
what is it where are we I don't look how
interesting look at different cultures
different beliefs you know how do they
come to that how do I feel about that
how do you know what do I think it's it
is a daily adventure you have your voice
it's there just do it do it do it do it
create you know don't let anyone stop
you from from being creative you do it
and and that confidence will come that's
why I say you know people there's no
right way to do it you know there's no
right way you do have your voice it's
it's there and it's uh it's a matter of
you just finding that confidence you
know yeah you bet I love this message I
told you agree with it you know the more
you practice the better you're gonna get
I practice these YouTube videos I've
gotten better at making YouTube videos
go back to my channels to the results I
practice at snowboarding I've gotten to
be a better snowboarder right anything
you practice that you're gonna get
better you practice a language you're
gonna prove your language skills you
practice marketing you're gonna prove
your marketing skills practice practice
practice
leads2results and knowing that you can
do it leads to confidence you can do it
again and take the next bigger step and
I think if you're here you want to go to
hear that maybe let me seem like a huge
step but going here may not be that big
and then when you get to here you can go
here and you can
here and then you can get to that big
point and sudden you've covered a huge
distance and so practice definitely
helps the thing I would add to it those
who are finding your confidence is I
think you can also model it and I know
that this really helped me I think about
you know my life my business I model
Steve Jobs and Donald Trump and Bill
Gates Walt Disney and Kanye West and
tons of different entrepreneurs a
helicopter for different things not that
I want to be Donald Trump not that I
agree with everything that he's saying
but there's ways that they position
themselves in ways that they talk and
things that they do that you can learn
to not be like anybody else but be the
best version of yourself and so Bill
Gates in particular when I was starting
my first business and I was sucking and
failing and not making any money and I
wanted to quit seeing how Bill Gates
started Microsoft and went from nothing
to building a successful company from
zero to his first million seeing how he
did that gave me the confidence that I
could do it too and so that's why I love
modeling success so much is partly why I
created this YouTube channel and why we
have so many famous entrepreneurs being
covered and featured is because I
believe you can learn from other
people's successes and gain confidence
through their actions as well by
creating an environment around you that
builds you up that makes you feel great
right that can let you do great things
give you the confidence that if he could
do it or she could do it if Oprah could
they would have Martha Stewart can do it
the Steve Jobs can do and the Bill Gates
can do it then maybe I could do it too
and so practice but also model success
so the question of the day today is how
do you find your confidence leave me in
the comments below I'll join the
discussion I'm also trying to build this
channel up to have a million subscribers
so anything you can do to share it tell
your friends about it get the message
out I really really really really
appreciate it thank you guys so much for
watching having that
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso